on legends i don't get nervous anymore
uh not at all
acting no
because also it's like i there you you
you've
you've got it you you could do it again
and again and you know this character uh
and i know this character um
but auditions yes
and
i think you know when i go on my next
project and i'm playing a different
character i'm sure i'll be
i'm sure every actor is right before
they get a part
they're always nervous as [ __ ] i hear
from the biggest actors
and then once they do a take or
something just get it out
then they can kind of relax but they're
all everybody's the same you just want
to impress you want to be good you want
to be on it and i [ __ ] hate nurbs
yeah i just want to be honest it doesn't
it doesn't some people say it does it
gives you that energy gives you that
drive but for me it's debilitating
sometimes it's too much
and just ultimately it's like just
[ __ ] listen listen to the other actor
which is something we all forget yeah
but when it comes down to it that's the
number one thing just listen to the
other person
and bounce off that person yeah they
talk about that with improv they talk
about that with acting but i found that
with when i'm not listening forget it
you're talking to a
a beginning actor i'm just i could be
really kind of like winging it
but it doesn't seem connected and
sometimes i've had like i don't i don't
know what's going on i don't know what's
going on the other actor goes are you
listening to me and i go
[ __ ] do another take i got this
just forgetting that i wasn't really
listening i was thinking of my [ __ ] yeah
do you deal with that ever
um
i mean for sure for sure i think
we everybody does um
and i think i'll notice that sometimes
where or you're working with an actor
and it's like they have something that
there is response to what you say and
then like they repeat it but they repeat
it as written not how you said it and
you're like you're not listening not
real
or they or the night before they were in
front of the mirror running their lines
and this is how i'm going to do it this
is how i'm going to say it
and they don't realize by but it changes
by the way you know you respond to other
by responding to what the other actor is
giving you that's why i really like
meisner because it's all about
it's all about that it's the pinch ouch
like
uh nothing
you you don't do anything unless
something makes you do it and everything
is off the other person and i actually i
went into i think it was season six or
something with and i had all my like
acting icons and things on my trailer
wall and you know and it was the whole
thought of all of those things where
it's like you don't do anything until
something the other person makes you do
something and nothing not self-generated
and
and then i the first scene that i come
on and to do
they're like okay but like
um
we need your eyeliner tight so like
don't actually look at the actor and we
need to and it was like okay uh and all
of these things that were just stripping
away
everything that you're uh used to doing
or or that make you feel like you're
it's real and it's in the moment and
because so much of acting is where
you're like
okay now i'm i there's a dragon and it's
flying and i'm i'm looking at it and
it's like you're not looking at anything
there's nothing actually there and
you're having to self-generate things
and so it can be hard to kind of
keep that balance that is hard
um
especially do you have to deal with a
lot of that on legends like seeing
things that oh this is gonna how it's
gonna be this is gonna be the cgi thing
and you guys gotta react to it and just
trusting is there a lot of that yeah oh
yeah for sure do you hate that
um
yeah
yeah i think so it's just harder it's so
much easier when you have anything even
if like they give a laser pointer
like that moves
it's like
thank you so much because it's like
everyone's trying to like have matching
eye lines and and the same with with
directors where like you're like please
talk me through it
give me something you know i think i
would be that guy i would be like it's
it's just this it's just a giant dragon
in the sky follow that light and it's
the fire comes out of its mouth and it's
[ __ ] just would you hate that no
that's what you want okay good because i
felt like i was i would annoy but some
some directors that if they don't
some directors it's where and they're
like you're scared
and now and it's like and they're like
don't i don't know
it's it's better to be like
and you're like
uh have anything anything to react to
right
do you get i want to know this
because no i've never asked this one
anybody like brandon ralph stephen when
you do the multiverse when you do flash
batwoman
um
legends
arrow you get the picture do you do you
get paid
for
extra when you go on the flash you get
paid for as an ep it's an episode of an
episode of the flash
so if you're doing an episode of arrow
and at the same time you're gonna do an
episode of the flash their eighth
episode and you're on your 15th you're
getting paid for a full episode on flash
and a full episode on arrow that's dope
you